tell me how the rehearsal went yesterday
run me through what you were doing and
how it all went
yesterday we rehearsed in the morning
with their majesties and rehearsed the
second part of the ceremonial and then
in the afternoon it's quite a long day
we did we did a full walk through so
that means that we started with the
processions that had formed up outside
the building
and and then went straight through the
entire liturgy and today's a dress
rehearsal it's a run through it'll be
very smooth yesterday we were stopping
and and working on some details it went
really well
which bits are you most worried about
given the complex nature of what has to
happen
I don't think I'm really worried about
about any of it I feel a bit for those
people for whom this is a first or a
very unusual visit to Westminster Abbey
and they find themselves uh right in the
sort of Spotlight of the stage of a
coronation having to move in a space
they don't know they're an awful lot of
people moving quite quickly with an
awful lot of
startling pieces of regalia that's it
will be extraordinary to see it needs to
be precise
how did the king seem to you
the King was was relaxed
and very gracious took time to thank all
the people around him who are making
this happen
so whilst he hasn't a huge burden on him
a lot for him to do he doesn't give the
sense of being a man who's really
anxious about this not at all how are
the children
uh it was wonderful to have them here
and I could see them watching with huge
interest
in the past there have been issues with
a crown getting it the right way round
you have to handle it what's the secret
what is your secret uh our secret is not
to type it's a thread to it because
someone removes them but just to
practice picking it up and handing it to
someone and having so rehearsed the
number of movements that it is the right
way around by the time it gets to where
it needs to be and you've had replicas
to help with that so we are still
working with replicas of the two crowns
from yesterday we started rehearsing
with the real Rod the real scepter which
was just extraordinary can give me a
sense of the scale of this ceremony the
spectacle of it it's actually quite hard
to do that because
everything is on a really startling
scale I'm the dean of Westminster I'm
used to ceremony on a national level
even I think this is pretty jaw-dropping
you have the most extraordinary
ceremonial dress you have the most
extraordinary uh pieces of regalia being
carried through the Abbey the music is
absolutely spine tingling there are a
lot of processions and
is with all the reggaea how does that
sit with you in a cost of living crisis
um
there have been there have been a number
of decisions quite significant decisions
all along the way which mean that the
cost of this is far below the
expenditure in 1953 which actually
wasn't a period in which this country
was profoundly affluent either an awful
lot of what you are seeing
are items that have been cared for over
a very long period of time so this is
this is a confident bit of display of
our past it's not it's not actually what
you see in the app is not actually a
colossal display of contemporary
spending
is there a risk that there's a lot of
show here but it's light on relevance
for people
uh of course I hear that conversation uh
the the difficulty here is that there is
actually deep meaning uh in an awful lot
of what we do we understand that uh we
live in an environment in which for very
good reasons people no longer know the
stories behind these things so it's a
shame I think that people will see
things and not realize what the meaning
always is
um but if people can dig a little bit
they'll um there are interesting things
being said and done
you're going to be that
be their most solid
you who will
happen
I just wonder do you do you personally
believe that the king is being appointed
by God
no and I don't I don't really think
that's quite nailing the language uh
that we are using uh what happens at an
anointing I'm a priest I anoint babies
uh at baptism uh and I see candidates a
confirmation being anointed uh clergy
are anointed at their ordination so uh
this is much more to do with being set
apart a moment of focus uh there's a
particular role here it's a
concentration on that
I'm wearing one of our coats but it was
a cope worn at the coronation of Charles
II so that that's the 1660s so that's uh
that's quite exciting and Charles II
Charles III uh for me uh the day will be
very busy it'll be very focused but
there are in all of that there are there
are moments when uh the sheer deep
seriousness and the history of it I'm a
historian it it is just spine tingling
he stays finding me because obviously we
know William the Conqueror came here we
do
what does that mean to you knowing that
we've got this history we've got the
Kings going way back buried here
so I know as I stand uh just in front of
the coronation chair that just behind me
really just behind me is the tomb of
Edward the first it's his chair it was
made for him just behind me is is Edward
the Confessor it was it was his church
that Duke William came to in 1066
so uh there's this there's all that
resonance all those Echoes going on Deep
Roots